Hi, everyone. In this video, we're going to go and take a look at layer materials looking
and using our old system to do so. And then other following videos, we'll look at the
new system, as well as the mega scans approach. So let's get started. What we're
going to do is first approach looking at this older way, is to be able to create
two material functions. And these material functions, we're going to layer in such a
way. So we can then stack them and pull them into a material parent. And in that
material parent, we'll be able to adjust things because we have function inputs in
those material functions, and to get things to look and layer the way that we
want. So I have a step by step in my slides. And I'm not going to walk you
through these in the slides per se, but I'm going to show you actually show
you and you can follow along with the slides and even look at the material
samples that I have in my scene. So let's go and jump into Unreal and get
started with that. So in my scene, you'll see that I have a simple
material layered object here. And I also have another one that's a bit more
complex. Now this one I built a while back for Disney. And you can probably
guess why there was snow. So I built this so that they could see how the
layers would work with a snow scenario. And that kind of rhymes no scenario. And
what I'm going to build here is a simple moss once you get an idea. And
then we're going to do an overview of this complex layer material and
another set of videos. Then later, we'll look at the two other ways
to be able to approach this. So let's go ahead and jump into this
one. So first up, we're gonna have to make a couple of material
layers. So let's go ahead and go into our class folder. We're going
to go to our in class material. And for this, we're going to make a
new folder. So let's go and do that. This new folder, we'll just
call this vid demo. In here, let's go ahead and make a
material function is what we're going to need. So you guys
should have learned material functions in our other videos.
So you're pretty probably vets at this point, you know your
way around a few things in Unreal, not your first rodeo. So
we're going to go to this material function and activate it.
Now this first material function, we're going to call this one
MF underscore moss. Let's go and make another one. So I'm
gonna right click here, go to materials again, I'm going to go
ahead and click on material function again, click right
there. And we'll call this one MF underscore, we'll call
this wood. Now to keep these a bit different compared to our
sample. And if you're following along, so you don't get
lost, and pulling the wrong one, let's go and mark these
appropriately, so that you can make sure you're getting the
right one. So we'll call this underscore new. And we'll call
this one underscore new also underscore new on the suffix
here on the very end. There we go. So let's go and
double click on our moss one, let's come pop that up. He's
off screen, so they pull him back. And I'm going to walk
you through some of the things we need to do and grab.
So one of the first things we want to do, you'll see you
will get a warning. This is kind of par for the course, we
want to turn this off. And we can right click here and say
stop, preview note. And you'll see the error go away.
So what we want to do here is set up our moss and get
this set up so that we can control visually kind of what
it's going to look like. So number one, let's do a texture
sample came up here in the T key. Now, I recommend you do
open the parameters, but you guys get the idea of how
to do that and just right click and convert to a
parameter. But we're just going to keep things a little bit
faster here and not worry about that. You should already know
how to do that. Let's go full screen. So you can see
everything and get those in the right place. And let's go
ahead and grab the appropriate texture that we need. So in
this case, we're going to go to our details. And here
under texture, we're going to do t underscore and we're
going to add moss. And then we should be able to get
our moss albedo. There we go. So awesome. So we want to
use a little bit of the power node here to do a little
bit of darkening, because mosque can come in pretty
bright. And at least what we can do is fix that. So if we
want to, again, if you want to, you can convert to a
parameter call this albedo. Am I going to do this with
every single texture because you get the idea should get
into this habit. I'm just re emphasizing that. And then
we're going to go and do power to the power node. And
then if we want to, we can go ahead and convert,
promote to a parameter. So we have a scalar parameter. In
the scalar parameter, we'll just rename this sucker to a
darkening control. There we go. And we'll just plug our
albedo right into that base of that power node. And
you can use a multiply if you want to, it's up to you
how you want to tackle that. But the reason why I'm
using a power node primarily is because we're going into
the fuzzy shading material function. And yes, you can
pull in material functions inside the material functions
to let that mess with your head. So let's type in fuzzy
shading. This is going to give us a nice little kind of
gradient, not a solid sudden change with the moss. So we
do fuzzy shading. I'm going to pull that power node
right into here. And again, you can experiment with
different setups here. This is primarily what I'm going
to be working with. I'm going to move my output
result out farther out here. That's gonna make things
a little bit easier. And what we want to do is also
control color. So I'm going to pull this string here
and we're going to type in multiply. Let's grab
multiply there is and in that multiply, we're going
to also create a constant. This can be a three
constant node. So give me a finger three key left
click. There we go and choose the color we want. I
think I chose like a really pukey green wasn't
quite the best green in the world. Doesn't look
like vibrant moss. This is closer to moss here.
Little bit closer when I am before
I make myself giggle sometimes. Alright, so we're
going to go ahead and grab this and pull this
into the beach out there. And I'm gonna pull this
up right here. Now again, you can promote that
variable if you want to. It can be a little bit
helpful. We're not really making instances of this
in this particular case. But if you were to
elaborate on this a bit more, you can get into
that habit. I like to get into this habit
anyway. This is really up to you. Let's set that
darkening note to 0.3 forgot to mention that. There
we go. Cool. And now what we want to do is get
into a make attributes. Let's go and make
attributes. There we go. Make material
attributes. And the reason why we're doing this
is then this adds a little bit more customization
to what we want to do and opens up all the
things that we need for this look and feel. And
it is a very good habit to get into in this
particular workflow. Now you'll notice in the
fuzzy shading, we have normal, we have core
darkness, we have power, and we have edge
brightness, we want to be able to make
scalar parameters for that or just parameters in
general. So I can right click in here, just
promote this if I want to. And actually, yeah, I
don't want to promote that way. We do want to
promote these three, we need an actual normal
connected here. So let's go to the core
darkness. And I'm gonna say promote to parameter,
pull this down, set this to like, let's
think, what is my setting? I think I said is 0.5.
Yeah, I think that's right. And then let's go
ahead and promote this one. There we go. Pull
that down and set this to zero for now just
as a placeholder. And we'll do the same thing
here. And again, you can edit these if you want
to later on. Pro to variable, pull that down
and just leave that zero for now. Cool. All
right. So we got our base set up here.
Obviously, it's not going to show up. So we
preview, we're not really connected yet. So we
can pull that in ahead of time if you want to.
And then if you want to, you can also do a
preview here just ahead of time. It goes
straightforward. Nothing right home about stop
preview. There we go. Alright, so let's go
and set up the rest of it here. Let's go
and hit the T key. And we're going to pull in
a normal. So let's go ahead and pull that
normal in. And I just have it set as called
normal. That's fine. It's gonna be any
normal you want. You do want them to match
though, if you can, in this case, we'll just
call this t underscore normal, two k, that
should be the right one. Pull this over. And we
can draw this straight into the normal. Now
you can add more of those normal details
like I've taught you in other classes. But for
now, I'm just going to pull it right in
there. And I'm going to pull it right into
the fuzzy shader to give a nice little get
that fuzzy shader effect in there, which
will work really nice. Get a nice little
almost as a built in type of you think of it
as like a built in drop off and all that. So
it actually works pretty well. Alright, so
let's get back to it. So add a few more
things just one more just a little bit of
roughness control. So we'll do a T for
texture. Again, keep finger left click to
get that T in there. And we'll just pull
in some roughness. And this one is just
like, called t underscore is gonna be any
rough you want. Obviously, you do want it
to match the texture of this one, I just
have rough 2k underscore 2k. That's fine.
And then we'll go ahead and I will keep
my finger the one key, get a constant in
there, set that constant to 0.9. That
seemed to work pretty well when I was
playing with this key, my finger the M
key, and then we're going to go ahead
and go into the B channel. And then
we'll grab this one and go into the
A channel. And we'll move this in up
here to roughness. Now some of the
texture names may have changed in your
files. I sorted these a little bit
differently. So it may not be rough, it
may actually be grass rough. And some
of these sometimes that makes a match.
If I can't find a rough, I'll just
grab something else from somewhere else.
And again, you're more than welcome
to do that. It's all up to you what
textures you want to use, and how you
want to get everything working in the
right area. And I just double clicked
on that string node, if you're
wondering, just giving this to look a
little bit less noodley, and a little
bit cleaner in breakdown. Cool. So you
should have what I have at this point.
This should be exactly what you're
going for. And in the next video,
we're going to go ahead and build
the wood material function and get
things set up in that direction.
Thanks again.